It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最忙碌的时候，我的连接依然保持稳定。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个不会稍纵即逝的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. probably know the stereotypes about only children, that they're lonely, spoiled, and maladjusted, they're selfish, and they don't know how to get along with others. Even as the U.S. birth rate falls, few people seem to think that being an only child is a good thing. A 23 Gallup poll, for instance, found that just 3% of U.S. adults think the ideal family size is one child. Myths about only children have deep roots in psychology, but in recent decades, researchers have disproven many of those long-standing beliefs about how growing up without siblings affects people. So what have they found instead? Do only children differ from kids with siblings in any
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。大家可能都知道关于独生子女的刻板印象，认为他们孤独、被宠坏、适应能力差、自私，而且不知道如何与他人相处。即使美国的出生率在下降，似乎很少有人认为独生子女是一件好事。例如，2023 年的一项盖洛普民意调查发现，只有 3% 的美国成年人认为理想的家庭规模是一个孩子。关于独生子女的神话在心理学中根深蒂固，但近几十年来，研究人员已经推翻了许多关于在没有兄弟姐妹的情况下成长如何影响人们的长期固有观念。那么，他们发现了什么呢？独生子女与有兄弟姐妹的孩子在任何
significant way? Are they lonelier? Are they less happy? Or are there advantages to being a singleton? Do only children benefit from getting more resources and parental attention? Do they become more successful as adults? And how do beliefs about only children and their outcomes in life differ between the U.S. and other countries. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Tony Falbo, a professor in the Department of Educational Psychology at the University of Texas at Austin, and one of the world's leading experts on only children. For more than four decades, she has studied how siblings, or a lack of siblings, affect a variety of outcomes, including people's
重要的方面有什么不同吗？他们更孤独吗？他们更不快乐吗？还是说成为独生子女有什么优势？独生子女是否受益于获得更多的资源和父母的关注？他们在成年后会更成功吗？关于独生子女及其人生结果的观念在美国和其他国家有何不同？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校教育心理学系的托尼·法尔博博士，她是世界上研究独生子女的顶尖专家之一。四十多年来，她一直在研究兄弟姐妹（或缺乏兄弟姐妹）如何影响各种结果，包括人们的
academic achievement, psychological adjustment, and loneliness. Dr. Falbo is an APA fellow and won the 2007 Newman Proshansky Award from APA's Division 34, the Society for Environmental, Population and Conservation Psychology, for her contributions to the field of population psychology. Dr. Falbo, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for inviting me. So in the introduction a moment ago, I mentioned some of the stereotypes about only children, that they're more lonely, spoiled, selfish than other kids, for example.
学业成就、心理适应和孤独感。法尔博博士是美国心理学会（APA）的研究员，并因其对人口心理学领域的贡献，获得了 APA 第 34 分会——环境、人口与保护心理学会颁发的 2007 年纽曼·普罗尚斯基奖。法尔博博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。刚才在介绍中，我提到了关于独生子女的一些刻板印象，例如他们比其他孩子更孤独、更被宠坏、更自私。
Where do these stereotypes come from, and why are they so common? I think these stereotypes just come from common sense. I mean, people assume that if you are only one child in a family, you don't have somebody to play with, and as a result, you might develop neuroses, or maybe your parents will overprotect you and you won't get out and about to have the kinds of experiences that are important. for children, or maybe they will overindulge you, and so you might be selfish. So sort of like common sense, I think, that motivates this stereotype. But of course, that's not scientific. That's
这些刻板印象从何而来，为什么如此普遍？我认为这些刻板印象只是源于常识。我的意思是，人们认为如果你是家里唯一的孩子，你就没有玩伴，结果你可能会产生神经官能症，或者你的父母会过度保护你，导致你无法走出去，获得对孩子来说很重要的那种经历，或者他们可能会过度溺爱你，所以你可能会变得自私。所以我认为，这是一种激励这种刻板印象的常识。但当然，这并不科学。那
just, you know, people's impression. Right. That's the myth, you know, and a lot of many common sense conclusions often, you know, come down to being not really supportable by evidence as we do science trying to evaluate it. Is that really true? So that's, you know, the question of whether only children were selfish, lonely, and maladjusted. It was really motivating my early research long ago in the 70s and 80s. Well, let's talk about loneliness. Many people believe that only children must be lonelier than kids with siblings. And is there any evidence to support that.
只是人们的印象。没错。这就是神话，你知道，许多常识性的结论往往归结为在我们进行科学评估时无法得到证据支持。这真的是真的吗？所以，关于独生子女是否自私、孤独和适应不良的问题，确实是我在 70 年代和 80 年代早期研究的动力。那么，让我们谈谈孤独感。许多人认为独生子女一定比有兄弟姐妹的孩子更孤独。有什么证据支持这一点吗？
The evidence is a little weak. Maybe when we think of loneliness, you know, we can think about something sort of like a dispositional, that something is permanent, part of the kid. they're just kind of depressed and feeling alienated because they're alone a lot. And that kind of, we measure that and we don't find that only children score higher on that kind of measure. And in fact, in some places like in China where there are many, many millions of only children, their children score less lonely than kids with siblings.
证据有点薄弱。也许当我们想到孤独时，我们可以想到某种类似于性格倾向的东西，即某种永久性的、孩子的一部分。他们只是因为经常独处而感到沮丧和疏离。我们测量过这一点，但并没有发现独生子女在这一指标上的得分更高。事实上，在像中国这样有数以亿计独生子女的地方，他们的孩子在孤独感上的得分甚至低于有兄弟姐妹的孩子。
So, you know, there's this dispositional idea of this is like a person. permanent fixture of a person growing up without siblings. They don't score as lonely as others, that they in fact do fairly well and sometimes even they're less lonely than others. It is the case, however, that only children do spend more time alone than other children, but that doesn't necessarily mean that they are lonely during that time. And it's also the case that some of the research done on how children spend their time and who are they spending their time with, that only children are more likely to spend their time with their mothers than are children with siblings. So it's more one-on-one time for an only child. And then when they look at like peer
所以，关于在没有兄弟姐妹的情况下成长是人的永久特征的这种性格倾向观点，他们并没有像其他人那样感到孤独，事实上他们表现得相当不错，有时甚至比其他人更不孤独。然而，独生子女确实比其他孩子花更多的时间独处，但这并不一定意味着他们在那个时间里感到孤独。此外，一些关于孩子如何度过时间以及与谁共度时间的研究也表明，独生子女比有兄弟姐妹的孩子更有可能与母亲共度时间。所以独生子女有更多的一对一时间。然后当他们观察像同伴
activities, a sports club or going to Girl Scouts or something, that only are as likely as any someone with a sibling to participate in that. So I think the assumption is that if people, children spend more time alone, they will develop this chronic sense of being alone and lonely, but that doesn't seem to be the case. So people tend to think that only children must have some social deficits, that they won't be as good as kids with siblings at making friends or getting along with others. Now, is there evidence to back that up? Well, one study was done on kindergartners.
活动，比如体育俱乐部或参加女童子军之类的活动时，独生子女与有兄弟姐妹的人参与的可能性是一样的。所以我认为人们的假设是，如果孩子花更多的时间独处，他们就会产生这种长期的孤独感，但这似乎并非如此。所以人们倾向于认为独生子女一定有一些社交缺陷，他们不如有兄弟姐妹的孩子那样擅长交朋友或与他人相处。那么，有证据支持这一点吗？嗯，有一项针对幼儿园儿童的研究。
There was a very large sample, and they had teacher reports on interpersonal skills of kindergartners, they also asked the parents the same question. And they also had their reading and math scores for, you know, a kindergarten. And the teachers reported that the people without siblings at that time were, you know, deficient in their interpersonal skills. But parents didn't report that. So there's no difference in how the parents were reporting it. And only children were having better vocabulary, better reading and math skills for that age group. But when you move along in the ages, kids grow older and they spend more time in school, they have more opportunity to interact with their classmates. So when you look at evidence from, let's say, people age 12 and older,
样本量非常大，他们有老师关于幼儿园儿童人际交往能力的报告，他们也问了家长同样的问题。他们还有幼儿园儿童的阅读和数学成绩。老师们报告说，当时没有兄弟姐妹的孩子在人际交往能力上存在缺陷。但家长们并没有这样报告。所以家长们的报告没有差异。而且在那个年龄段，独生子女拥有更好的词汇量、更好的阅读和数学技能。但随着年龄的增长，孩子们长大并花更多时间在学校，他们有更多机会与同学互动。所以当你观察 12 岁及以上人群的证据时，
that they have as many friends as do others. You know, they report having as many friends and they get as many mutual selections as other kids. So apparently over that period of time, kindergartners are able to kind of adjust and learn how to do what needs to be done in order to have a reasonably successful social life. Are there advantages to being an only child? For example, do only children do better in school or in life, presumably because they got their parents undivided attention and resources?
他们拥有的朋友数量和其他人一样多。你知道，他们报告说拥有同样多的朋友，并且像其他孩子一样获得同样多的相互选择。所以显然在那段时间里，幼儿园的孩子们能够调整并学习如何做需要做的事情，以拥有一个相当成功的社交生活。成为独生子女有什么优势吗？例如，独生子女在学校或生活中表现得更好吗？大概是因为他们得到了父母全神贯注的关注和资源？
Right. So that's one of the main advantages is that, you know, the only children are probably getting a lot of parent conversation. And so that would elevate their vocabulary earlier on in life. And that might be a benefit early years of school. So they might be identified as being better at school because they have this experience, more deeper experience with hanging out with adults. So many times parents of only children, just take the kid with them wherever they go. And that is not so easy to do for parents. If you have several children trying to corral them around is very difficult.
没错。所以主要优势之一是独生子女可能得到了很多与父母的对话。因此，这会在生命早期提高他们的词汇量。这可能是学校早期的优势。所以他们可能会因为有这种经历，与成年人相处有更深层的经验，而被认为在学校表现更好。所以很多时候，独生子女的父母只是带着孩子去任何地方。而对于有几个孩子的父母来说，这并不容易做到，试图把他们聚在一起是非常困难的。
So you tend to leave them at home, whereas if you just have one kid that's manageable. So I think there's a good chance that only children spend more time in adult activities. Like it wasn't designed for a child, but they can get to observe it. And I think all that kind of benefits them cognitively early on. Now, I think it's a reason to believe that, you know, as, as, people with siblings grow up, particularly if we just have one sibling, for example, as you grow older, you might be able to catch up with only children so that, you know, they might, you know, have that kind of experience talking with other teenagers and adults, which happens later in their,
所以你倾向于把他们留在家里，而如果你只有一个孩子，那是可以管理的。所以我认为独生子女有很大机会花更多时间参与成人的活动。虽然不是为孩子设计的，但他们可以观察到。我认为所有这些在认知上对他们早期都有好处。现在，我认为有理由相信，随着有兄弟姐妹的人长大，特别是如果我们只有一个兄弟姐妹，随着年龄增长，你可能能够赶上独生子女，这样他们可能也会有那种与青少年和成年人交谈的经历，这发生在他们发展的后期。
in their development. You know, so it's not like it's a permanent IQ advantage or vocabulary advantage for only children. By the time they get to be like 25, I think probably there's not much of a difference at all. What about the notion that only children are more likely to be spoiled? And I'm not even sure what that means. But has anybody done research looking at that? Is that even a concept that exists in psychological research? Yeah, that's, that was hard. When I started, and I was trying to see if only children are more spoiled than others. I mean, how do we measure spoil? You know, and so one of the kind of get around this, I was looking at the research that have been done with parent-child relationships.
所以这并不是说独生子女拥有永久的智商优势或词汇优势。到他们 25 岁左右时，我认为可能几乎没有什么区别。关于独生子女更容易被宠坏的观点呢？我甚至不确定这意味着什么。但有人做过相关研究吗？这在心理学研究中是一个存在的概念吗？是的，这很难。当我开始研究时，我试图看看独生子女是否比其他人更被宠坏。我的意思是，我们如何衡量宠坏？所以为了绕过这个问题，我查看了关于亲子关系的研究。
And so with Denise Pallee, I did a meta-analysis, you know, the research that had been done in the first 80 years of the 20th century on only children. And, you know, we expected that only children would have a negative relationship with their parents because they're spoiled and over-indulged. But that's not what we found. In fact, the quality of the relationship seemed to be better than if you had, you know, more children. children. And so I think there is also, you know, evidence that children who, you know, just the only kid, you go to the dinner table, yeah, mom and dad, they're rather than spoiling you
所以我和丹妮丝·帕利一起做了一项元分析，研究了 20 世纪前 80 年关于独生子女的研究。我们曾预期独生子女与父母的关系会很糟糕，因为他们被宠坏和过度溺爱。但我们发现的并非如此。事实上，关系质量似乎比有更多孩子的情况要好。所以我也认为有证据表明，作为独生子女，当你坐在餐桌旁时，妈妈和爸爸，他们与其说是宠坏你
or indulging you, you know, what they're probably going to do is quiz you or talk about, now, what did you do in school today? And then the kid has to explain it. Then they talk about it. Whereas, you know, if you have multiple siblings, you know, little kids in their, parents are just wanting to get the food in and the parents are talking to each other, not to the child. They don't get this didactic interaction. You know, it's probably, you know, the kids obviously don't absolutely need this, but there's kind of this expectation for adult conversation and behavior for only children earlier on. So rather than being spoiled, I'd say they're kind of pushed harder. So that's sort of American data that we have. But then in the Chinese case, they, you know, they mandated only children
或溺爱你，他们更可能会盘问你或谈论，今天在学校做了什么？然后孩子必须解释。然后他们讨论它。而如果你有多个兄弟姐妹，家里有小孩，父母只是想把饭喂进去，父母在互相交谈，而不是和孩子交谈。他们没有这种教学式的互动。你知道，这可能不是孩子绝对需要的，但对于独生子女来说，早期就有一种对成人对话和行为的期望。所以与其说他们被宠坏了，不如说他们被逼得更紧了。这就是我们拥有的美国数据。但在中国的情况下，他们强制实行独生子女政策，
and urban families, and so there are millions of them produced there. And the original stereotype, starting in like in 1980, emerged that the English language version was Little Emperor, that they would become little emperors. And that's part of being spoiled and just sort of lazy because everyone does everything for them. That's a little emperor stereotype. So that's what they were expecting to see.
在城市家庭中，所以那里产生了数以百万计的独生子女。最初的刻板印象始于 1980 年左右，出现了英文版的“小皇帝”，他们会成为小皇帝。这是被宠坏的一部分，只是因为每个人都为他们做一切而变得懒惰。这就是小皇帝的刻板印象。所以这就是他们预期会看到的。
And so a lot of research in China was done. And it seems like rather than being indulged, And what happens in China is they're pushed very hard because if the parents know this is my only kid, they want that kid to be perfect. They have to be high scoring in school. They have to have perfect social behavior, you know, moral behavior. So, you know, kids are really shoved very hard. They're in school, six days a week, 12 hours a day.
因此，中国进行了大量的研究。看起来他们并没有被溺爱，在中国发生的情况是他们被逼得很紧，因为如果父母知道这是我唯一的孩子，他们希望那个孩子是完美的。他们在学校必须取得高分。他们必须有完美的社交行为，道德行为。所以孩子们真的被逼得很紧。他们每周上学六天，每天 12 小时。
So if anything, you know, they're not spoiled, but really the expectations are very, very high. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th.
所以如果有的话，他们并没有被宠坏，而是期望值非常非常高。你的夏天从家得宝的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四头燃气烧烤炉开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅招待客人，仅需 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。
U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Now, you've written and spoken about growing up as an only child yourself. Is that what got you interested in doing this research? And how do you feel today as an adult about having been raised as an only child? Yeah, it's a great question. Thank you. Well, how I got into this topic originally was that I was an only child. And I was at UCLA and the psych department as a graduate student. And we were learning about stereotypes and the impact of stereotypes on behavior. And at that time, we were talking about men versus women, blacks versus whites,
仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。现在，您已经写过并谈论过自己作为独生子女成长的经历。这就是您对这项研究感兴趣的原因吗？作为成年人，您对自己作为独生子女被抚养长大有什么感觉？是的，这是一个很好的问题。谢谢。我最初进入这个话题是因为我是一个独生子女。当时我在加州大学洛杉矶分校心理学系读研究生。我们正在学习刻板印象以及刻板印象对行为的影响。当时，我们正在讨论男人与女人、黑人与白人，
and how the stereotype would lead to people reacting to and interpreting behavior in a certain way. So I thought, wow, there's a stereotype about only children. Maybe that is motivating people to have another child. And a few demographers had put this question in some of their surveys, their fertility surveys, and found, you know, in the 1960s, 1970s, that, you know, people were saying, oh, yes, I'm going to have another shot because I don't want my first one to be an only child. So that stereotype was, in fact, motivating people to have a
以及刻板印象如何导致人们以某种方式对行为做出反应和解读。所以我心想，哇，关于独生子女也有刻板印象。也许这正在促使人们再生一个孩子。一些人口统计学家在他们的一些调查、生育调查中提出了这个问题，并在 20 世纪 60 年代、70 年代发现，人们说，哦，是的，我要再生一个，因为我不希望我的第一个孩子成为独生子女。所以这种刻板印象实际上正在促使人们生
second shot. And so this was, you know, part of my research and something I found, you know, very interesting that this stereotype was having a significant effect. Now, in terms of my personal opinion, you know, I never felt bad that I was an only child. I was a nerd. I loved to read. I didn't have any trouble at all spending my time. So, you know, my mother was the one who would say, no, you've got to get out and do stuff. And she insisted that I do it. And, you know, bless her heart, she did that and really help me. She said very often to me, I don't want you to read about life. I want you to live it. So even though she was happy I did well in school, she really didn't want me to just be an indoor reader. I had to go out and engage with other kids. And,
第二个孩子。所以这是我研究的一部分，我发现这非常有趣，这种刻板印象正在产生重大影响。现在，就我个人的观点而言，我从来没有因为自己是独生子女而感到难过。我是一个书呆子。我喜欢阅读。我花时间一点问题都没有。所以，我的母亲是那个会说，不，你必须走出去做点什么的人。她坚持让我这样做。而且，感谢上帝，她确实这样做了，并真正帮助了我。她经常对我说，我不希望你从书本上了解生活。我希望你亲身体验它。所以尽管她很高兴我在学校表现出色，但她真的不希望我只是一个室内阅读者。我必须走出去与其他孩子互动。而且，
you know, the natural environment and get exercise. And so, you know, I benefited from her perspective on childwaring. Now, it's possible that, you know, other only children don't have that kind of experience and they might, you know, stay inside and be really miserable. My mother-in-law, for example, was an only child. She was born during the Depression. And she, And it was just after the pandemic of the early 20th century. And so her mother was very frightened of her catching some disease. So her mother never let her go outside and play. So she would tell me about times when she was a little girl,
自然环境并进行锻炼。所以，我从她对育儿的看法中受益匪浅。现在，有可能其他独生子女没有那种经历，他们可能会待在室内，变得非常痛苦。例如，我的婆婆就是个独生子女。她出生在经济大萧条时期。那是 20 世纪初大流行之后。所以她的母亲非常害怕她感染某种疾病。所以她的母亲从不让她出去玩。所以她会告诉我她小时候的一些时光，
she would look out of the window and see other children playing outside. And her mother would never let her go out there. Oh, God, that's terrible. I know. So she ended up having six children. Just a curious question. I mean, do only children tend to have more imaginary friends? Did you have like an imaginary sister because you wished you had one?
她会从窗户往外看，看到其他孩子在外面玩耍。而她的母亲从不让她出去。哦，天哪，那太可怕了。我知道。所以她最终生了六个孩子。只是一个好奇的问题。我的意思是，独生子女是否倾向于有更多的想象朋友？你有没有因为希望有一个姐妹而想象过有一个姐妹？
No, I didn't have. There's no evidence about that at all that they would be. That'd be a great story to tell, but I really, I'm always paying attention to what's coming across, you know, in terms of new research and new ideas. But if somebody tested that hypothesis, you know, they couldn't find any results that really supported the idea that only children may have, you know, a sister or brother is imaginary. Well, let me ask a more serious question. What about advice for parents of only children? Is there anything special they should be doing to help their kids have a happy and healthy life?
不，我没有。没有任何证据表明他们会那样。那会是一个很好的故事，但我总是关注新的研究和新的想法。但如果有人测试过那个假设，他们找不到任何结果真正支持独生子女可能有想象中的姐妹或兄弟的观点。好吧，让我问一个更严肃的问题。对独生子女的父母有什么建议吗？他们应该做些什么特别的事情来帮助他们的孩子拥有幸福健康的生活吗？
Well, I guess I'll just, you know, give the advice of my mother. It seemed to work well for me. I was perfectly happy as an only child. And that is it, you know what, the kid to spend all the time on a screen. and this is really the problem now. You know, you get toddlers on screen for hours, and then it just gets worse as they get older. And that means then you're not physically active. You're not outside. You know, and parents just need to,
嗯，我想我只会给出我母亲的建议。这对我来说似乎很有效。作为一个独生子女，我非常快乐。那就是，你知道，不要让孩子把所有时间都花在屏幕上。这确实是现在的问题。你知道，你让蹒跚学步的孩子在屏幕前待上几个小时，然后随着他们长大，情况只会变得更糟。这意味着你没有进行体育锻炼。你没有在户外。你知道，父母只需要，
maybe more of an issue for just one child, but it's easier to do. Just take the screen away, put them in a sports school, or, you know, have them go outside and explore the leaves that are falling from the trees or, you know, doing something and, you know, kind of keep them from overindulging on screen time and being able to go outside and play with other children and just be physically active. So these are, I think, issues that now I think are probably more challenges for people who just have one child. What's the trend in the U.S. in particular?
对于只有一个孩子来说，这可能是一个更大的问题，但这样做更容易。只要拿走屏幕，把他们送到体育学校，或者让他们去户外探索从树上落下的叶子，或者做点什么，让他们不要沉迷于屏幕时间，能够出去和其他孩子一起玩，保持身体活跃。所以我认为这些问题现在对于只有一个孩子的家庭来说可能是更大的挑战。美国的情况趋势如何？
Are only child families becoming more common? And what's it looking like abroad? than in China? Yeah, so internationally, there's a lot of low fertility, which leads to that people having no children or just one child. And so you see that in almost any part of the planet. It's very surprising. Even countries like Iran, where we assume, you know, they have the mullahs and they have the conservative Islam and so on. But they're not producing lots of children. And they have a lot of only children there. And of course, what is motivating that, I'm sure, is there's a lot of uncertainty, economic deprivation, you know, the place might explode into some kind of a war. And, you know, one of the things your parents are saying, I want to be able to protect my child
独生子女家庭变得更普遍了吗？国外的情况如何？比中国呢？是的，在国际上，低生育率很普遍，这导致人们没有孩子或只有一个孩子。所以你在地球上的几乎任何地方都能看到这一点。这非常令人惊讶。即使像伊朗这样的国家，我们假设他们有毛拉，有保守的伊斯兰教等等。但他们并没有生很多孩子。他们那里有很多独生子女。当然，是什么促使了这一点，我相信是因为有很多不确定性、经济匮乏，这个地方可能会爆发某种战争。而且，父母们说的一件事是，我希望能够保护我的孩子，
and make sure that I can support them so that they can become, you know, a decent adult when they grow up. And if you're very concerned about not having enough money to feed them even or no shelter, than, you know, you tend to reduce the number of children or have no children at all. So we see a lot of young adults now so concerned about climate change and, you know, the world coming to an end and, you know, into some, either you're being flooded or burned, you know, you think, well, do I want to bring a child into this world? So a lot of people are stuck with no children at all.
并确保我能支持他们，这样他们长大后能成为一个体面的成年人。如果你非常担心没有足够的钱喂养他们，甚至没有住所，那么你往往会减少孩子的数量或根本不生孩子。所以我们看到很多年轻人现在非常担心气候变化，世界末日，要么被洪水淹没，要么被烧毁，你会想，我真的想把孩子带到这个世界上吗？所以很多人根本没有孩子。
And so it might have one. Then they're wondering, should I have any more? and actually Bill McKibbon, as a famous environmentalist, wrote as there in many, many books and won many awards for his environmental work. He wrote a book in the 90s called Maybe One. And he interviewed me to talk about, well, maybe this is one approach to having some impact on global warming, which is just to have one kid, as opposed to having two or three or four. And so his whole book is supporting that idea. And so I think it was an early idea of, well, it's good to become parents maybe. And if you just become a parent, then just one is a good idea.
所以可能有一个。然后他们会想，我应该再生吗？实际上，比尔·麦基本是一位著名的环保主义者，写过很多很多书，并因其环保工作获得了许多奖项。他在 90 年代写了一本名为《也许一个》的书。他采访了我，讨论也许这是对全球变暖产生影响的一种方法，那就是只生一个孩子，而不是生两个、三个或四个。所以他的整本书都在支持这个想法。所以我认为这是一个早期的想法，也许成为父母是件好事。如果你只是成为父母，那么只生一个是个好主意。
So that was, you know, Bill McKibbon's take on this. Well, given that book and many of the other things that you just said about people being concerned about bringing children into a perilous world, do you think the public's attitude toward only children and single child families has shifted? Gosh, you know, those opinion polls just keep suggesting not, you know, and you were mentioning that Gallup poll, and that just continues to be the case. So when people are asked the question, what is the ideal family size? It now covers around two, and it's not zero or one. So, you know, if you're going a little beyond that, you go to three.
所以这就是比尔·麦基本对此的看法。好吧，考虑到那本书以及你刚才说的关于人们担心把孩子带到一个危险世界中的许多其他事情，你认为公众对独生子女和独生子女家庭的态度发生了转变吗？天哪，你知道，那些民意调查一直表明没有，你提到了那个盖洛普民意调查，这种情况依然存在。所以当人们被问到理想的家庭规模是什么时，现在大约是两个左右，而不是零或一。所以，如果你稍微超过那个数字，你就会去到三个。
So that's the range where people see it's ideal. You know, I think people rarely plan to just have one. one child. I was one of the weird as I adopted just one child. But most people, they have one assuming it's going to be a firstborn and then things happen either biologically they can't have another child or maybe their life situation as such that doesn't work out. So they end up with just one child. It wasn't a planned event. They didn't think of it as ideal, you know? And so just anecdotally, every now and then I'll meet people and they'll tell, oh, I only had one kid. That's all we could do, da, da, da, and there's almost like apologizing for this, you know, that they didn't
所以这就是人们认为理想的范围。你知道，我认为人们很少计划只生一个孩子。我是一个异类，因为我只收养了一个孩子。但大多数人，他们生了一个，假设它是第一个，然后事情发生了，要么在生物学上他们不能再生一个孩子，要么他们的生活状况不适合。所以他们最终只有一个孩子。这不是一个计划好的事件。他们并不认为这是理想的。所以只是偶尔，我会遇到一些人，他们会告诉我，哦，我只有一个孩子。我们只能做到这样，等等，他们几乎是在为这个道歉，他们没有
achieve that ideal state. So I don't know that the one child family is going to be considered ideal or what, you know, young folks are going to want to do because, you know, there's plenty evidence out there that it's okay as a choice. But, you know, that belief that you need to, at least so they have each other is certainly something. It's very, very, very much inside our thinking as human beings. Now, psychology historically has also fed into this myth. I mean, can you talk about where it came from originally? Because I think that some of our earliest pioneers basically promulgated the idea that only children were messed up.
达到那个理想状态。所以我不知道独生子女家庭是否会被认为是理想的，或者年轻人会想要做什么，因为有很多证据表明这作为一个选择是可以的。但是，那种你需要至少让孩子有伴的信念，无疑是人类思维中非常根深蒂固的东西。现在，心理学历史上也助长了这个神话。你能谈谈它最初是从哪里来的吗？因为我认为我们最早的一些先驱基本上宣传了独生子女很糟糕的观点。
Yeah, that's right. Gee, Stanley Hall, famous. You know, they probably have a lecture series at APA, you know, named after him. I mean, and he was a man of his times. you know, 18th century, New England, living, grew up in a rural area. And his notion is, how does a child learn how to play? Well, they run around in the fields out there in the woods with, you know, their siblings. You're kind of, it's not an urban environment where kids are just next door.
是的，没错。吉·斯坦利·霍尔，很有名。你知道，他们可能在 APA 有一个以他命名的讲座系列。我的意思是，他是他那个时代的人。18 世纪，新英格兰，生活在农村地区。他的观念是，孩子如何学习玩耍？嗯，他们在田野里，在树林里和他们的兄弟姐妹一起跑来跑去。这不是一个城市环境，孩子们就在隔壁。
You're on a farm somewhere and it's quite a distance. People just didn't drive off anywhere, you know. So the assumption he had was, you know, in order to develop that's have that fun, kind of early childhood where you're exploring and playing with other children. He just assumed that was normal. And then when he did develop more scientific approaches to study of human development and then suggesting how to guide families and parents and teachers, he was collecting individual cases of people who would come to him as a clinical worker
你在某个农场，距离很远。人们只是没有开车去任何地方。所以他的假设是，为了发展那种有趣的童年，你在探索并与其他孩子玩耍。他只是认为那是正常的。然后当他确实开发出更科学的方法来研究人类发展，并建议如何指导家庭、父母和老师时，他收集了那些作为临床工作者来找他的个人的案例，
and trying to get help for their children. And it turned out that many parents of just one child would come to him. And he said, well, there's more of them than people with three children or 12 children. So, you know, therefore, that one child probably must be particularly flawed. So I think he's reported to have said something like, only children are a disease and to themselves. So that was his conclusion. It's hard to find that in writing. But apparently he lectured about this many, many times.
并试图为他们的孩子寻求帮助。结果发现，许多只有一个孩子的父母会来找他。他说，他们比有三个孩子或 12 个孩子的家庭多。所以，因此，那个孩子一定特别有缺陷。所以我认为据报道他说过类似的话，独生子女对自己来说是一种疾病。所以这就是他的结论。很难在书面材料中找到这一点。但显然他多次讲过这个问题。
He went all over the United States lecturing about how to bring up a child, what's appropriate child development. And I think I had a lot of positive things to say in general. But when it come to only children, he definitely had a negative attitude. And I think that influenced the field early on. We talked a little bit about the research you've done in China. And I'm just wondering anything that we haven't talked about from that work that was interesting to you that you discovered was unexpected. perhaps. Oh, that is an interesting question here. You know, if you had a more psychodynamic perspective, you would assume that the people who were only children grew up because their parents were forced to have
他走遍美国，讲述如何抚养孩子，什么是适当的儿童发展。我认为我总体上有很多积极的评价。但当谈到独生子女时，他绝对持负面态度。我认为这在早期影响了这个领域。我们谈了一些你在中国所做的研究。我想知道除了我们谈到的之外，你在那项工作中发现的任何有趣或意想不到的事情。也许。哦，这是一个有趣的问题。你知道，如果你有更心理动力学的视角，你会假设那些因为父母被迫只生一个孩子而长大的独生子女，
just one child, that, you know, you as that child would think, oh, well, when I get a chance to have three kids, I'm going to have three kids. You know, obviously that's what I should do, or two, at least. But what I didn't expect would be that what we're seeing now in China is a you know, generations of only children going through and not really either wanting to have any children at all or maybe just having one. A few of them, the government now is trying to get everybody to have three, but they don't have a way of coercing. They've lost that control. So they can't coerce people to have children. And so some people are having two or three, but they're not getting the birth rate up as a result.
作为那个孩子，你会想，哦，好吧，当我有机会生三个孩子时，我要生三个孩子。显然这才是应该做的，或者至少两个。但我没想到的是，我们现在在中国看到的是一代又一代的独生子女，他们并不真的想生孩子，或者可能只生一个。政府现在正试图让每个人都生三个，但他们没有强制手段。他们失去了那种控制力。所以他们不能强迫人们生孩子。所以有些人正在生两个或三个，但结果并没有提高出生率。
Actually, the size of the population of China is in decline. So just to wrap up, what's next for you? What research heard you working on now? What are the big questions you still want to answer? Right. So I'm getting more interested in screen time and the influence on the neurological development, the cognitive development, but also the social development. and mental health of children.
实际上，中国的人口规模正在下降。所以最后，你接下来要做什么？你现在在研究什么？你仍然想回答哪些大问题？是的。所以我对屏幕时间及其对神经发育、认知发展的影响越来越感兴趣，同时也关注儿童的社会发展和心理健康。
And I think that only children may be more vulnerable to more screen time, but I don't know that. So right now I'm using some nationally representative data sets trying to run those analyses and figure that out. And the trade-off typically is with more screen time, there's less physical activity. And that's negative. We have an epidemic of obesity, even among children now. And less activity is not the direction to go into. So, you know, I want to see if only children, therefore, are more likely to get less activity. I don't know.
我认为独生子女可能更容易受到更多屏幕时间的影响，但我不知道。所以现在我正在使用一些具有全国代表性的数据集，试图进行这些分析并找出答案。通常的权衡是，屏幕时间越多，体力活动就越少。这是负面的。我们有肥胖流行病，即使在儿童中也是如此。而减少活动不是正确的方向。所以，我想看看独生子女是否因此更有可能减少活动。我不知道。
This is an open question. That's when I'm working on. Well, Dr. Falbo, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been very interesting. You can read more about Dr. Falbo's and other psychologists research on only children in the September issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. Go to www.ap.org backslash monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org
这是一个悬而未决的问题。这就是我正在研究的。好吧，法尔博博士，我要感谢您今天参加我的节目。这非常有趣。您可以在 APA 杂志《心理学监测》九月刊中阅读更多关于法尔博博士和其他心理学家对独生子女的研究。请访问 www.apa.org/monitor。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集，
or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方。如果您喜欢所听到的内容，请订阅并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。感谢您的收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。